foreign
all right so let's start with today's
webinar so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
srikari Krishna Kumar and I would like
to welcome you all for today's webinar
on introduction to band Maddox in our
program as biology is saturated with
complex data sets that have to be sorted
explored and looked into anyone handling
data generation analysis or decision
making Based on data has to gain some
level of data science skills in most
biological and biomedical settings you
will be expected to run or Implement
programs written in python or R our
programming offers a complete range of
functionality that is you can leverage
to perform in-depth statistical analysis
visualization and annotation getting
started can be hard programming is like
learning a new language and that is why
we offer easy to follow structured and
simple coding tutorials designed around
bioinformatics challenges with mental
guidance in this upcoming introduction
to bioinformatics in our program that
will commence on December 1st and the
aim of today's webinar is to just
introduce the participants to program
details such as program Mentor program
curriculum overview course structure
expectations deadlines intertor outcomes
and program registrations so before we
begin with today's webinar let me also
take a brief moment to introduce you to
the team behind the program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
ecd use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics project
training that has been completed by over
24 000 cars from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and due to this fast
growth our team is working with local
and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine program
Logistics and adapting them to the needs
of students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omic's data analysis and
students will also have access to the
omics logic resources but how does it
help Advanced band marriage teaching
women's logic is important for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bandformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
the omics logic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics that includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and apigenomics data science that
includes using R and python as well as
cheminformatics and example projects of
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your research
work and users will be given directions
to access the T bioinfo platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data and the platform includes demo
pipeline as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipelines and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multi-atomics
platform and how to view the various
courses and example projects you need to
first sign up on the omics logic learn
portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles this
could be your Facebook LinkedIn
Instagram or ID or even Twitter a brief
bio about yourself that will consist of
your educational background and research
interest and the mentors can view your
progress under the activity Tab and the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the core system
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under these certificates tab so with
that now let me walk you through a brief
demo on how you can sign up on the
portal
so kindly make sure
to
visit the link and sign up along with me
so that you can get access to all of the
resources that we will be discussing
during today's program
so okay so those of you who are new to
this portal and who do not have an
account uh here is a demo on how you can
create one so for that just click on the
option that says create an account that
you see here and you here you can enter
your name give an email ID and enter a
password or you also have the option to
sign up using any of your social media
handles this could be your Google
Facebook Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter so with that I'll just
pause for a couple of minutes so that if
the participants have any queries on
signing up they can let me know and for
those participants who have already
signed up you can just click on the
login now option that you see here and
just simply click on the sign in so I'll
just wait for a couple of minutes so
once you have done signing up on the
portal you can leave a done in the chat
box and if you already have an account
on the portal you can just leave a yes
so that
um I can get a fair count of those who
already have a pre-registered account on
the portal
if you're facing any technical issues
you can mention that as well all right
so we have one participant who has
already signed up and I'm waiting for
rest of the 50 plus participants to sign
up
uh today we would like to make it more
interactive so to get access to all of
the courses and program structure you'll
it will be really great if you could
create an account so that we can go
along and uh learn about what are the
various topics that will be covered
so I'm just going to click on sign in
since I already have an account on the
portal
all right so once you sign in you'll be
able to see the various courses and
example projects that are there on the
portal so the topics range from oncology
infectious diseases to machine learning
courses as well
uh all right and uh so for for instance
if you're interested to learn about R
you can just simply enter the keyword R
and it will show up all the courses and
example projects that makes use of our
programming language and let's say you
have
um another field of Interest suppose
let's say it's oncology then you can
simply enter
become oncology or cancer and that will
also show you all the courses and
example projects that will help you uh
uh learn the topic all right so with
that let me walk you through the next
important part about setting up your
profile so that uh click on the tab that
says welcome back with your email ID
and once you click here uh you'll be
able to see your profile and how do you
edit the profile for that you can just
click on the button that says profile
and here make sure to upload your
profile image and your name has to be in
proper capitalization and you can also
link any of your social media handles
for instance I have linked my LinkedIn
account and my arc ID and also make sure
to uh add your bio that is it will
consist of your educational background
and research interest
and once you have done you have updated
your profile now let us also explore
some of the various tabs that are there
in the portal that is under the activity
tab as I mentioned the community manager
and the mentor of the program will be
tracking your learning progress and to
view the various courses that you're
currently taking it will uh be shown
under the courses tab for instance
currently I am taking the effect of
non-antibiotics and wets inform example
projects
and once you complete a research project
as a part of the research fellowship
program uh you'll be able to upload it
under the projects Tab and uh if you're
enrolling for the program for instance
the introduction to by informatics in
our program the program uh progress will
be appeared under the program staff and
finally after completing the assignments
and the required quizzes uh the course
certificate steps will be appearing
under the uh certificate stack so with
that I'll just pause for a couple of
minutes and if the participants have no
queries
uh we'll be put to start with today's
session
so are we good to go is that a yes or no
is anyone facing any queries
uh all right so I'm just going to uh
pass on the stage to Dr raghavendra
Lakshmi 9 to start with today's session
he'll be giving you an overview of the
program structure and the various topics
covered followed by that we'll be
discussing the program registration cost
as well so along the way if you're
having any queries uh all right so we
have a question from Muskan can we
upload the certificate on our LinkedIn
profile after completion of the course
yes absolutely I have uploaded it as
well and it helps me network with more
people on LinkedIn so that's yes so if
the participants have any other queries
please let me know
along the way you can share your queries
as well and we'll be happy to answer
your queries uh towards the end as well
so with that the stage is all you'll
stop travel
thank you SRI gauri uh hello everybody
Welcome to today's session so let's have
a Hands-On session and let me set up my
screen share so quickly uh can you type
in in the chat box how proficient are
you in any coding uh environment so zero
being absolute no ways and uh 10 or
above 8 or 7 being you you will be able
to get codes from publicly available
resources like GitHub and stack Overflow
and then modify that to your needs so
please let me know a beginner would be
something like one two and moderate
experience would be like five okay
excellent
so let me find this thank you thank you
slow let me set it up
okay
thank you
thank you very much thank you everybody
so okay we will take this real slow and
we will perform uh analysis uh that will
help you understand
how we could process and how we could uh
use R to perform rnic data analysis or
transcriptomics analysis Let's see we
are going to evaluate our cater data
from publicly available resources and
and get
let me set it up my um
pardon me for a moment let me rejoin
because my zoom is not looking at my uh
screen
okay
loading loading
I think it's it's starting to okay now
it's it's fine
can you see my screen what do you see do
you see the program page yes so we can
see your program page thank you very
much okay thank you very much
so uh
yes thank you uh let me set this up
so I have opened up chat next to you
next to me so that I can follow your
responses in chat so uh we will start
with for example uh absolute basics of
getting started with bioinformatics in R
so this Associated resources will
actually help you uh load for example a
data in R and it will help you
understand the syntaxes let's take a
look at one of the uh resources that's
okay
data processing and visualization now
let's go there
so I'll just quickly tell you how the
structure how the coding resources are
structured and then we will start with
some EX
some demonstration some analysis let's
see
so uh this is
yeah so this is how it is structured
first we start with introducing you to
what is the aim or what is a
uh problem statement that we have for
example in this lesson we are going to
address a different data processing and
data visualization uh options that are
available in R to visualize any
structured data so uh
so first you will have options to learn
the code or you will get where you will
understand
in blocks of course the exact code
commented properly and around the code
we will give you explanations of what
each and every components of these R
code is going to give tell you right for
example in this simple code where we are
going to load a table into an
environment like R so first we have to
use a function that tells R to do what
we want to do like load the table and we
have to give this function the location
of where you will find the table and
this location can be from your computer
and for
um
for ease of access of the data we have
uploaded a lot of these
curated data assets to our data sharing
platform and then we will give you uh
those links so that you can follow along
as we go in the analysis and then what
follows is the characteristics of your
data I will come a little bit more
detail into what these arguments are in
a short while so uh to explain you what
is is happening so this is a code and
what you see around this is going to be
different parts of the code explained
and their typical output actually given
right um for example if you are going to
plot something we will give you what to
look for if you are going to use this
plot or use this code to plot a data set
so uh we will start something like uh
like loading the data into our
environment and then explore the data or
process the data in a necessary format
so that we can apply some statistical
analysis to this data right and this
will include for example remove some of
the duplicates and this will include for
example remove some of the not
applicable values and you will get
everything in in more detail and how
this affects the data and how that
increases or improves accuracy we will
get to that in in Morehead and then we
will explore again this talks about some
transformation in the data scale like
like logarithmic transformation you will
also learn about why is it necessary how
is it useful and how to do that so and
finally you will visualize the data some
like this simple visualization which
plots the data in a box plot format to
understand the data distribution across
different samples so you will get more
more and more
um in
explanations on how to perform not only
this analysis and other data
visualization options and how those
visualization are going to help us
understand the patterns of the data
how for example you can learn a little
bit about the data distribution in box
plot and what will you learn about for
example say in scatter plot and Etc so
when you keep exploring more and more
like you can come to hit hit map and
histograms and density plots etc etc so
there is a myriad of different uh
um exploratory data analysis that can be
performed and you will get lot of
examples in how to do this analysis and
how are how is it going to help us
understand the data and their pattern
generally in the omics data type and
then if you scroll down you will for
example perform
based on the understanding of the
of the exploratory data analysis you can
set up comparisons for the statistical
tests to evaluate our data patterns and
that is what we will do a little bit in
a short while and then followed by you
will have some introductions to what if
if you need Advanced statistical
analysis like machine learning and how
to use for example metagenomics data how
to make use of metagynamics data which
comes up with its own challenges and and
[Music]
opportunities to understand little bit
more about data so we will for example
uh in this whole curriculum we will
start with working with sequences and
covering some genomic variants in R and
then we will uh there um where we are
going to address how to perform or how
to use ours tools to understand
patterns in the genomics data analysis
output like a variant calling output and
how to
[Music]
identify the significance of those
variants and Then followed by um
followed by you will perform for example
Downstream analysis on transcriptomics
data which you will
do it today and then where we are going
to cover for example starting from
um obtaining data from publicly
available resources like we take a
publish to take a paper and then find
the data and then take the data in the
necessary format and then start
performing this analysis right and then
over the course we will also discuss the
pluses and minuses so couple of analysis
statistical analysis options
okay and then we will follow this up
with uh what if straightforward uh or
normal statistical analysis uh is not
sufficient for your data analysis in
that case we have to use um Advanced
statistical methods like machine
learning to understand the patterns in
your data so this uh this will also be
covered
um in the resources and then we are
going to finish or end the program with
analyzing or using ours tools to
understand metagenomics data which is
little bit different from the other
forms of data as it actually covers or
as it contains information from multiple
different entities like microbes instead
of one cell or an average dot cellular
expression or genomic information from
the cells that we usually deal with in
the genomics and transcription atomics
data so so let's start with for example
setting up some analysis in Google
collab so we will use
um Google collabs environment for two
days analysis so if you have not don't
if you do not have any introduction to
Google's collab
um Google's collab would be for example
let me get the link so all of you
whoever has Google link Google
support or ID can use account can use
this collaboratory notebook so you will
open up a page like this
so okay uh can you click on this
specific link and then open up a page
like this this is a Google allocated
resources for you to perform some simple
calculations in R and python
separately and use the shareability of
this Google's notebook to share it with
your peers with your friends with your
collaborators
Etc so that you can
use the collabs and their tools
effectively so that's what we are going
to do today also uh so if you see this
such a screen and you can actually
change the name of this collab here
like
my normal collab and then you have to
connect to the Google's hosted services
or resources so that we can run some
codes in this collaboratory environment
so we will simply press connect or do
something like connect to a hosted
runtime here so um all of you can you
connect if you connect it's going to
show
um something like this it's going to
show you something like this until it's
going to take a while and then it's
going to show you a green tick and then
some Associated uh
um
[Music]
um
resources that you are not resources
actually uh
um hosted run times right uh you were uh
yeah
hosts runtime that you will actually get
gain access to can you press this
connect and then wait for this
connection to uh work out
so please give give a one or yes in the
chat box when you see uh When You
observe a green tick mark next to its
connect
so we will discuss about what is the
data that we are going to discuss and
that we are going to analyze today
but before that we have to start setting
up some of the libraries and start
installing some of the modules and
libraries so we will let that install
and then come back and discuss the
data that we are going to discuss the
data that we are going to focus on today
okay looks like yeah good very good
excellent so now
um
now comes a little bit uh coding part so
we have to install this Library so I'm
going to copy this and paste it onto the
onto your chat box so
um
I'm going to copy this and paste it in
the chat box
so I'll paste it here
you copy this and paste it here right in
this code you see this code if this is
code is not activated double click in
this one and paste it here so do you see
a screen like what I have obtained
and then
once you have this one ready you can
execute this by pressing this run cell
option on this
play area or this uh
okay
uh specific uh
button so after you press that it's
going to keep installing for a while you
will see some outputs in this section
below but let it run so just let me know
if everybody is able to start installing
these packages that we are going to
need to use this
so give me a response in chat so it will
install something like easily from two
minutes to four minutes depending upon
maybe many of us are using it might take
a little bit longer so that we will use
the tan to discuss the data but yeah we
will do this here
okay yes some more yeses is everybody
here is it running is it working or is
anybody getting a problem
so this is absolutely necessary step for
us
installing very good not yet
okay uh alpana Sharma I think you you
did not wait wait wait wait for those
who are getting a error like Ruth and
alpana Sharma I think you are actually
uh installing this in no paste option
there use command V or control V from
your computer
so Google doesn't work very well with
right click and paste so you have to use
your keyboard shortcuts to paste
and Ruth and everybody please use for
example um
this link to open up a collab and don't
use any other link because you are
trying to make an R script run inside a
python notebook
so that is why you are getting an error
use this script to run for both of them
you will get the same extension so use
this uh
a link to open up the code and then
installing still installing it will
install like three to four minutes so uh
is root and alpana Sharma there please
open this up open the collab with this
link and then paste it and start
installing
are you there
let me know
yes very good thank you Ruth and what
about Alcona
yes yes okay
okay so let's uh look for the data set
the data set that we are going to uh
analyze today is from this publication
okay uh okay installing yeah it is going
to install for two or three uh minutes
so let's uh focus on this the data set
that we are going to understand today so
it's going to be this
all right data set
where we are going to
follow along the data that is present in
this publication to understand genes
that are that can be identified from
differential gene expression analysis uh
using something like yeah comparing
colorectal cancer patients with normal
patients that's what we are going to do
today so this let me copy this
um
publication
so from most of these Publications uh
either in PubMed uh
a link or any other link you can come to
the data part right and then under and
then get a link to where the data is
available for this publication right so
you can read more about the publication
what they actually identify based on
this right
[Music]
um
yeah so uh
[Music]
let's go down
yeah so they do something like they
compare for example
um gene expression data from colorectal
cancer compared to the normal cancer and
then uh gene expression data from
metastasized colorectal cancer compared
to the normal and also compared to the
cancer cells and and try to follow along
the risk factors or risk
risky genes whose expression might be
correlated with the metastasized
metastasis states of the cancer so
that's what they actually do that
involves lot of other analysis like
survivability analysis and etcetera so
this is an excellent
um
uh paper to go through to understand how
transcriptomics data can actually help
us
characterize the genes based on their
involvement in tumor progression right
and if you come down for example in the
data page right it's also available here
in the supplementary information but in
the data page
you will get a link to the gene
expression Omniverse database where you
click this and it's going to go to gene
expression Omniverse let's let me come
back it's already I have used it here so
um
this is why usually we look for data but
coming from the publication is another
way of getting to the data so
this is the repository in ncbi which uh
which hosts many transcriptomics data
and other omics data type so
here you can read little bit about the
data a little bit about this overall
design little bit about about the what
was studied and you can get you will see
something like this you can get how many
samples has been studied and more
importantly and what are these samples
and their sample annotations right we
have something like
um
2024 23
primary cancer tissue and then we have
something like 24 normal cancer tissue
and then we have a 20 yard metastasized
cancer tissue and their gene expression
data studied using High throughput
sequencing methods so this
page also has the uh
input data or not in the processed data
in supplementary file so you can
download this using this HTTP link or
the sample character characteristics can
also be explored from series Matrix file
so usually this is this is how we hand
access data but only for few of the
studies uh they are going to give an
alternative data
published data
link like this one has published their
data in ncbi and also in ebi links right
you should export both of them why
because when you download this specific
data right this data is going to open up
like this
and where
you will have each and you'll have the
expression levels Quantified for each
and every one of the samples in a
separate file so you will need uh
something like you'll need to load up
all of these files into environment like
R to merge them into one big table
usually that's what we get when you
perform a transcriptomics
sequence analysis or rnasic pipeline
analysis in the
big data by info server like Tower by
info server right but
ncbi data has
the gene expression Quantified for each
and every sample separately now this is
useful not to say that this is not
useful but for our purpose we will need
one big table that contains the
expression data for each one of the uh
samples tabulated accordingly so that is
and again if you download the series
Matrix file which is going to for
example give view the characteristics of
the sample
yeah okay
okay so how is your installing going on
it's still going on
has anybody uh
got their installation complete
and maybe many of us are using so it's
it's going to take a while
still going on yes
ongoing okay
anybody managed to complete this
ongoing May for many of you ongoing on
DC server okay the server BC now I think
many of us are we are starting to
uh
ongoing
showing cannot open file you have not
even opened file now
which link are you using Arjun
same link okay can you paste it
the recording will be shared and yeah we
are waiting for the installations to
complete I'm being very slow or I can
even slow down
so okay let it go through so we will
come back to this right uh okay let's
discuss little bit more about how to get
the data right so this is a series
Matrix file which is going to
um
a link for
okay
this is the link with which you can open
up an R I think now the server has
gotten to okay server has gotten to BC
uh
yeah maybe some of you can follow along
let's see
anybody managed to complete installation
that's why I thought we would uh finish
up the installation and then discuss the
data download it's going to uh take some
time
still installing okay it's been a while
okay so this is this is how you let's
see if uh let's explore this sample
characteristics and come back to it we
still have some some time some more uh
things to cover so
um
so we will download this series Matrix
file and that is going to for example
open up
like this so we have two files one file
or a bunch of folder which gives us
expression values uh measured for each
and every one of these samples
yeah okay
um this page link this is okay I will
get it okay it's here you don't have to
download this now because I have done
the download and I have uploaded the
file in GitHub or in shareable link so
that's what we are going to use but if
you want to explore the data page and
this is the publication you can you're
free to do so
here okay so um we have I have
downloaded this file let's go to the
file and
and take a look at what this file
actually shows us
so if you open this file for example in
um an Excel or in numbers so it's going
to open up like this not like this
yes like this so here you will find uh
um
the different characteristics of the
sample that is being measured and
yeah so here for example uh it's did it
stop abruptly
okay I think I have to open this in
Excel
sample characteristics where is this
yes perfect if you have R installed in
your computer you can use our studio to
uh do I mean to install and then follow
along that's going to be much quicker
because
um
yeah because
maybe many of us are trying to access
Google server so it is not actually uh
very responsive right now
okay can you paste the error sign rabbi
okay I think I should open this up in
um
jio accession this one is here
installation complete now great very
good so we will come back to that let's
if you open this in Excel my point is
you will find the sample characteristics
here and
um
thank you
let's open this up in Excel that's going
to be
so is the installation complete for many
of you
one complete that's great okay here
so here for example this is what we are
interested in let's see here uh we have
not only
um the characteristics like which sample
comes from which tissue here and whether
this sample is is a cancer sample or is
it a normal sample at what stage this
cancer or tumor tissue is so all of
these information is available in Sample
characteristics so you can download this
and then we can make use of this data
also to understand or to associate the
phenotypical data as this one with the
expression data that we are going to
download as I mentioned
um if you find uh
a data with uh
with ebi repository you can actually use
that repository to download more uh
visualization friendly data if you click
on this one
and you will see
for example
edit load anybody else has gotten their
installation complete
yeah so this this is a page that you
will get and you will have uh for
example
[Music]
um
data from here I'll give you the link
right now let me copy and paste the link
experiments yeah
important
yes for example this is the experimental
data and then yes so you can access the
expression Atlas experiment from here
and we get to that actually from this
link
I'll show you where this is
yeah so here you get uh you can download
the
um
experimental design or the sample
characteristics output and the same or
similar table but in a much
user-friendly way so you can download
this from here and you will find these
resources
okay I am going to give you this file in
a different uh link or different link
yeah
yeah so um
and then for example in this downloads
you will also find
all raw counts for this experiment so
that also you can download
so these two files if you download this
this is what you will get for example
all rock owns and
the same file or a similar different
Organization for the file that you
downloaded from ncbi right so this is
another experimental design that file
that both of these we can download from
here so I'll show you what these two
files will look like right and these two
files will look like the one that we
want to get our ncbi files processed to
our level where we can load it up in R
and then start analyzing this data so
this is the Experimental Design
Insulation is done very good
congratulations so this is the
experimental design file which you will
open up which you can open it up and
then this is what it will open up into
it's the same
so this is much more user-friendly
because
the organization is not horizontal it's
in a tabular format so you will find the
IDS and
the read IDs or files and they are
sample IDs and Sample characteristics
like which ones are primary tumor which
ones are metastatic and Etc and other
characteristics like for example the
stages of the cancer and yeah you can
use mainly uh
yeah more uh sample characteristics like
right where this is from from colon or
from Epic from liver where it is
metastasized to or whether it's a normal
sample so this this is what we will use
and for example uh your uh
tabulated file will look like this the
raw counts that we have downloaded from
the EM tab or ebi will actually look
like this let's open it up
I think I have opened this already yeah
installation is anybody has else gotten
their installation complete
I think I have this very good excellent
so uh
you can follow the ncbi link from the
publication that I pasted but you don't
have to use that to download data
because I'm going to show you or give
you this data that I have downloaded and
then uh made it available for you from
our GitHub account right so this is yeah
so this is what you will get right and
this is what uh this is how the data
this is the format of the data that we
will also obtain after you run uh rnac
pipeline for example in the Talbot
bioinfo platform from the first few
files that you can get access to in the
ncbi repository so that is there so uh
this has Gene IDs on the rows and this
goes for for example if I can yes
all the way to
58 000 transcripts and uh yeah their
their G names also involved in this one
and then for each one of their samples
their raw counts uh estimated and we
will get their raw counts right and this
is what we will analyze today so both of
these files are uh I have made it
available in the GitHub link so you can
use that as I uh paste along so after
this is complete for you and you open up
another code by pressing this plus right
insert code below press this you will
find a small box like this and in that
box you are going to
um
paste this this is the file that we are
going to load the design file and the
raw count file both of them you are
going to paste it like this
no sorry don't select and paste yes so
that's what you will get and it's
hopefully I can paste everything in this
one
yes okay can you copy this from the chat
and then paste it in the
um in another code block as I have done
can you do that and let's let me also do
it along with you after you have pasted
this then you will find this small uh
run the cell option and run it
and these two are the files that I have
downloaded from uh this ebi repository
and then
just do nothing put it in the GitHub and
I'm giving it sharing it with you so
that is easier that way
the power of ncbi uh
maybe sometimes we might have to
pre-process these files to a required
format to perform some of the analysis
but ncbi repository has links from this
one data page to the first few files
repository and from this one database to
all the other Associated options like
you can even find all the public
Publications there and yeah so um so
that is one hub from where you can get
everything associated with this one
resources so sometimes we can tolerate a
certain level of uh requirements to
reorganize the data as we get along
right so once if the run is complete
let's check what we have loaded so what
what did we actually do here in the
first part we have installed the
libraries which took forever and then we
have loaded the required libraries and
then here we have just loaded the sample
um like the X Prime X um like the
expression table uh into a data frame
called raw.counts and then uh we just
another
data frame called design will will load
the experimental design into themselves
so as I told you as we discussed so this
read.table function requires the path of
the file to be mentioned and Then
followed by some characteristics of the
file what are the characteristics of the
file I have to mention whether this file
uh has a header or not some of the files
might not have header and we have Header
information in the first row of the file
which tells what each column means to us
so I should tell or I should mention it
to ours load.data function that yes I
have header present in my data and the
the separator that separates each and
every column in my data is a tab so how
do I know that it is a tab right I can
open it up in in Excel and if you open
this up in an Excel it will show you uh
while importing it uh
[Music]
the character that separates the field
is tab right that's it it will show you
that in the input data option or uh for
sometimes you can observe that uh the
output or the extension of the file is
tsv which is tab separated version or
tab separated format so
um that we know okay then if it is
complete when it is complete open
another code like this insert a code
like this or press it up like this so
you will find a code like this here and
in here
mention or type head of design
and then run this
copy this and then please run this you
can if you don't want to copy and paste
you can run it along with me
so I'm just going to for example explore
the first few lines of the design data
frame I have loaded from public from the
from this GitHub link or from this file
this is exactly the file that we opened
in numbers or Excel to look through
their organization that's what we need
we just need to make sure that
everything is read in in a way that we
want like we don't have uh
um
foreign
yeah we if for example we don't
um we only need for example the Run
information or the sample IDs names and
their biopsy site or characteristics
biopsy site okay that's good and then if
this is done if you are here then open
up another code
along with me and then now we will find
or peek into the expression table right
that we have named it as raw counts
my head of rockons head with me display
the first few lines of my data frame
and
after you have done that
can you see this information
yes okay do you want me to uh yeah
okay everybody can be are here so
congratulations you have loaded the file
into ours environment now let's proceed
in full speed to analyze this uh file so
what are we going to do for example uh
this is what I have we have uh loaded in
in ours environment right instead of
head if you type just simply design
which is the name of our data frame and
then press it's going to
display everything so why do I display
everything I just need to
um
um find out what is the comparison that
I want to set up I have three types of
tissues right one is tumor tissue right
and then the next is normal tissue and
the next is colorectal tissue so I am
going to be interested in comparing
tumor versus normal so that will become
part of my comparison the time code is
set up so for that
um you can actually find out from this
or for example from opening this file in
a numbers format we will see or we
observe
right from the first sample to 18 right
you remember it started from two so from
the first sample to 18 sample we have
tumor tissue and from a 19th sample till
38 or 37th sample we have normal tissue
so that information we need and we have
several ways of separating which of
these IDs or file IDs belongs to tumor
are normal but let's take it really slow
and you will learn other ways in the uh
in our during the session or during the
program so that's what I'm going to
mention here so look I am interested in
the design section of the design file
which Compares or which has information
for for example primary versus normal so
that is up to 37th row right that's what
I found out so that's what I'm
mentioning here let me close this and
that's what I mentioning here right
design equals 1 to 37 so I'm copying
this
right just copy this
and then I will the next line open up
another code then press this and then
put it
run this
right I am just uh
pre-processing the design or the example
characteristics file to the required one
so if you run this you will not get any
output but run this and then based on
the account that I did or I have
um 18 cancer files or cancer
samples and 90 normal samples right
that's what I am going to create two
labels for my cancer or normal tissues
right and yeah this function is going to
repeat this one word this many times so
for example to this just to demonstrate
what it actually does
this this doesn't give you any output
Rabbi don't worry we are just
overwriting the design data frame with
the subset of the design so it's not
going to give you an output so for
example if I do this it's just going to
create cancer cancer 18 times and
similarly if you do this this is 2 for
example this function is to create a
label for our sample just like um yeah
just like the sample uh
just like the sample characteristics
that you find so we need this because we
have to prepare for example the analysis
design file that the differential gene
expression analysis will take so um take
this also that is what this is going to
do and I am going to open up next code
block or even below this don't do this
open up next code block and run this
right
and run this this also will not give you
any output please do that
so let me also uh catch up with you
so this I wanted you to do first
okay
then here I wanted you to this one and
this is also not going to give me any
output
that's fine
and then I am going to for example from
this raw counts right from this row
accounts I am going to extract
um
uh
select the variable of interest Gene
names and for example the design and run
so uh
where is this one okay here is this one
okay
um
raw counts design run okay okay this is
what this one select the variables of
interest and data and add Gene names
that is what this is going to run use
um
so
um
we are going to take this uh option let
me run this one
yeah so this run information right this
uh
run column is going to get uh added to
for example
um
G name I don't actually quite get this
what this section just wait a second let
me take this and
explore this
further
okay yeah
G name and design run is going to be
here
okay ah
okay so it is going to uh for example it
has to yeah so what if this one actually
does what this one actually does is uh
it's in a convoluted way that I've
written it okay um
okay so what this one actually does is
um this is going to uh subset your data
set for only uh
the first 30 say 38 right yeah first 37
comparisons that we are setting up right
so uh if you check uh this raw count
information so it has 56 columns as we
have all the uh um
uh all the samples and their expression
values measured so but people we don't
want everything we want only uh primary
tumor and normal as we have substituted
here right so that's what this is going
to do this is going to for example uh
load up the gene table this expression
table raw counts and then subset only uh
those samples for which I am interested
in so let's quickly do this
um and run this this is also not going
to produce any result right and run that
and then
um
yeah
okay once it is actually run and then we
are going to leave out for example for
the analysis purposes the gene names uh
inclusion or information from our table
so after this if you are there now I
want you to open up another code and for
example uh do this
right head
if you do this all you will observe is a
data frame which has 37 columns matching
our design our comparison design and
yeah six because we have added only had
first few lines of the code sorry there
yet
yes excellent so that's everybody's
progressing so very well
um so this is what we need so all of
these three blocks is going to first uh
take a subset of your comparison because
our data has three comparisons we want
to take a subset of our comparison
Define those comparisons right and then
make the expression table also filter
the expression table also based on the
data that we are going to compare based
on the samples such that we are going to
compare that's what we have done so far
and then we are going to create a
metadata data frame right this is also
required right
this is going to be in the next one
so open up error what is error let me
check the error ones but
others open up another code from here
I'm going to open up another code from
here and then paste this information
this is also not going to give you any
output and then run this
okay what is the error that you get
um
and please paste it there and
is everybody here finished up this step
after you are done this step excellent
so open up another code and then type
metadata
right with uppercase
and then enter right we should see an
output like this I'll come back to that
Omega
if you see an output like this so what
have we done so far after loading up the
data we have pre-processed or prepared
the input gene expression table to
include only the samples of comparison
and prepared or
prepared the comparison list from the
sample characteristics or experimental
design into a separate data frame called
metadata so everybody here they got data
frame 37 into two
you said object Gene table not available
so uh
did you run this did you run this
particular portion without any problem
um I think you have problems in this
particular portion the one that I have
blocked you did not run this probably
before the gene table so if you run that
then you will get this information uh
are done right
follow this along yes I will do that
this has to be run before the head Gene
table and followed by another block and
this and then followed by for example a
block where we are going to subset or
create a metadata data frame
and Then followed by printing out the
metadata right I'll take only another
five more minutes or five to seven
minutes depending on if everybody is
here this is the the flurry of uh uh
paste is specific to um Irfan who got uh
problems when she
um
try to execute this head Gene table so
is everybody here after you have printed
out metadata let's move along are you
here
so now we are going to perform
differential gene expression analysis
very good so this is what we are going
to perform
and open up another code and paste this
and run it again so now you got your
everybody's Pro you don't have to wait
for my Express
explanation what to do so paste this and
run you are going to see for example
outputs like this uh like what the
differential gene expression analysis is
actually performing You observe here we
are giving there are two inputs or three
inputs for uh creating this data from
Matrix for the differential gene
expression analysis using desec Library
the first one is a gene table that we
prepare the second one is a metadata
that we prepared both of these we
filtered from the original data and the
third is the type which is actually
um
the name of this column which tells
which sample is cancer which sample is
normal or which comparison that we are
actually performing to be exact and Then
followed by this is preparing the data
Matrix followed by performing the dec
analysis so it's going to run something
like it's going to estimate the gene
dispersion for for your samples uh it's
going to for example understand how the
mean of the genes per sample and how the
dispersion is actually
related and based on this this is going
to fit a glm model to identify the
Baseline gene expression of housekeeping
genes in the cancer samples and normal
samples and then it's going to find
differentially expressed genes for
cancer versus normal why it is not
working for your way what is the uh
what's the output that you get
what are you getting as an output
is everybody else made were able to
finish this
yes yes okay
okay then we move along so what do we do
next yes
yeah
yeah so what do we do next we are
actually going to for example uh
estimate how many genes are upregulated
and how many genes are down regulated
so that is what we are going to do in
this specific code block
so can you copy sorry can you copy this
and uh
okay can you run this in the next
Associated one
so after this what do you get can you
let me know
do you get this output
yes very good so what have we just done
we have out of four forty thousand or
gene expression right we have estimated
which ones are significantly
differentially expressed and from our
analysis we have set a very extremely
stringent p-value like like that's like
one in a million right that's that's
really extremely stringent p-valu and
with some correction to the adjustment
method why we set this p-value and why
we use this adjusting correction will be
explained a lot in the program right so
and now
um we also identified something like 121
genes that are up regulated and only 30
genes that are down regulated right
that's that's what we find from our
analysis in and so far so this
Statistics are very good for displaying
but how to make this uh presentable in a
in a in a for example plot like View
so for that we can use a volcano plot
option which we installed earlier so
open it up and paste this
and let me know do you get a graph or do
you get a plot
then this this one did not run for your
way then yeah we will
we will share this collab with you try
to follow follow right from the
beginning then it should not be a
problem for you okay
so did you get this output can you see a
plot like this
yes okay excellent thank you
so what did we just identify we have
identified genes that are significantly
differentially expressed and for example
you're getting error from metadata yeah
you you will you are not preparing some
metadata right yeah we both of you can
follow this collab when we share it with
you right so what if we just identify we
have identified based on log full change
and based on the pre-adjusted value that
we have calculated what are the genes
that are significantly differentially
expressed right and for example
um we can also have another version of
this uh plot where we are going to set
some stringent
cutoffs right so that we don't uh
display everything like a beehive so
this is this is very difficult to
interpret what is there and uh What uh
what these different dots mean so these
different dots are the genes that we
have identified them as differentially
expressed and this is a better uh
volcano plot where we are going to
display only few genes that are
differentially expressed right and this
is also based on some cutoff that we
have set up so what cut off the setup
how are we going to set up this cutoff
what do they mean what are the adjusted
value mean like pay cut off Main and
what is a fold change cut off mean and
how are we going to for example uh
display come from here to here where we
are displaying everything based on for
example our very lenient cutoff right
here based on the stringent cutoff we
are displaying only few of the genes
yeah and yeah I'm done I'll just be
so this analysis and what did what's the
biological implications of this we can
discuss uh much more detailed in program
but this is the basis of getting to
those 19 genes that are identified as
being significant in the tumor
progression for colorectal cancer based
on that paper right we are also
somewhere close to that right how many
genes here we get something like
um very close to for example 50 genes
less than 50 genes so this is yeah so
everybody there did you get this second
plot
excellent thank you very much and if you
have gotten the second plot this is how
you can take a data from publicly
available resources and follow along
some of the comparative analysis so this
is only differential gene expression
analysis only one lesson from uh from VR
uh program that we are going to cover so
we will do what to do before this
analysis and how to perform
pre-processing and what to cover after
this analysis if this is not able to
identify differentially X Plus genes and
what will we do next uh this one so with
that thank you for the patience and we
are going to
um I'm going to hand this over to Spurs
I believe
yeah
because
so it's me yeah uh thank you Doctor of
Indian for such extensive Hands-On uh
session and uh so I'll be quickly
explaining the registration part for all
the participants who have like joined
and want to further enroll in this
program and to learn more Hands-On as
well as conceptual and
theoretical skills so let me share my
screen
yeah definitely everyone will get a
recording after uh like the session is
over we'll be sharing the insights of
this session also we are sharing the
YouTube link here on the chat itself
maybe or just we can share the link so
just be has shared
the link already so please copy this
link and you can go through
with the process and everything
in detail too so okay
uh so could you please confirm like if
my screen is visible
oh yes brush it is listening yes it is
visible thank you thank you sir thank
you
um so uh
so today was the free webinar for the
introduction to bioinformatics in r or
getting started with r and the program
is going to commence from 5th of the
December and it's uh like a three month
long generation depending upon which
particular participant is interested in
which uh tenure
so uh as we all know that the data is
growing and uh with time everyone if you
are going for if you are seeking a job
or if you want to do further research so
like coding has become like a kind of a
must-have skill for a bioinformation or
for a normal biologist also so with this
particular program we will be enabling
you we will be enabling the students the
researchers the biologists The Faculty
everyone uh so that they can gain both
the conceptual as well as the practical
skills related to the uh are with
bioinformatics you will be leveraging to
perform in that statistical analysis
through this program visualization and
annotation and much more things
so now as I scroll uh down this is the
program overview this is the program
curriculum which you can see on my
screen so we will be starting from like
the basic introduction to getting
started with bioinformatics and art and
transiting you all from beginners to
intermediate level and then in the end
and the advanced level we'll be
discussing about how you can draft your
research uh question your research
proposal and further work work on your
research project so the very first uh
session which will be like which we'll
be conducting on December 5th it will
include topics like introduction to Big
Data in bioinformatics introduction to
bioinformatic languages using the code
playground are loading data in art Etc
so as you can see these are the titles
and the topics covered and also the
associated online resources
have been mentioned here the second is
working with sequences in our annotation
of genomic variance in our
transcriptomics data processing and
visualization in our then also we are
covering statistical aspects
differential gene expression machine
learning aspects metagenomic analysis
and R and so on so we will be
like covering uh three different
multi-amic study domain that is genomics
transcriptomic metagenomics with machine
learning and statistical aspects so as I
move further
there are three different tenures in
which you can enroll further and those
are of for 45 days 60 days and 90 days
and uh for those who are from obviously
we have participants across the globe so
uh anyone who wants to see the pricing
for D3 uh different tenures they can
accordingly choose the map where they
are residing for example if someone is
residing in a U.S so they can choose it
for like a U.S like uh us then if
someone is in India they can choose
accordingly to the to the currency
that's INR then in Euros then in uh
Brazil Etc and if someone is living in
Nigeria or an African past they can
choose the naira currency so for now uh
I have displayed the payment Link in INR
and if you can if you want you can
change it to USD also to eyebrows also
to euros also Etc so now I'll be telling
about what are the basic what are the
common resources which one would have
access to they'll enroll in this
particular program so the basic access
is
uh online tutorials you will be having
access to the omics logic loan portal uh
then you will be having access to all
the example research projects on
omixological or portal they're the
coding sessions the session recordings
obviously the scripts also for our uh
then online meant to Support Online
technical support and once the program
is over the program is finished you will
receive a certificate of completion also
and then you will have access to some
example Cloud pipelines on a t bioinfo
platform so these are the common
resources which one would have for all
the three ten years now what's the
difference between the three tenure is
in 45 days you will have access to group
discussions live q a sessions or live
sessions in 60 days and 90 days tenure
you have two different opportunities in
60 days 10 years you will be having
access to one-on-one Mentor session for
example you are going through uh with
some of your session or you are going
through with uh some of your coursework
or lesson onomix logical on Portal and
you like you came up you came across any
question or query so we can fix a
one-on-one Mentor session of yours with
the mentor and you can get your queries
clarified it would be a kind of a 15 to
20 minutes exploratory meet with the
mentor and the second uh important
feature or the most or you can say the
opportunity which you'll have is that
you have an opportunity to draft a
research proposal and present it to our
expert Mentor for the valuable feedback
and evaluation then for the 90 days
tenure with one-on-one Mentor sessions
you have an opportunity to draft a
complete research project and present it
to the inventor and also you can further
work on that uh research project and get
it published in a good peer-reviewed
general journal so this was the
resources which you'll have access to
when you enroll for this particular
program and uh now we are providing
scholarship to uh everyone like early
bird kind of scholarship to everyone and
uh I guess uh SRI gory or just speak and
share or just be has already shared the
coupon code so I'll just quickly show
you how you can proceed with the payment
checkout also for example if I'm
interested in 45 days tenure I'll click
on the buy now option and
in just a moment slowly yeah so as you
can see that uh
here they're asking for if we have any
coupon code so the coupon code is take
all in caps e a k e take 20 and then
apply
so the coupon code is successfully
applied you can see here the cost has
been uh decreased earlier the actual
cost was in INR 7500 and now it is
decreased to 6000 so it's a 1500
discount a 20 scholarship for all the
Indian contacts uh and if for example if
I'll do it for uh like USD people who
are living in us also
I'll just show you a glimpse
so now you can see the pricing has been
changed for 45 days it's a dollar 150
then uh for 300 for 60 days it's dollar
300 and for 90 days it's taller 450. so
now if I'll click again on buy now I can
simply write here type uh take 20
and then apply
and as you can see that here the pricing
has been changed to Dollar 120 from
Dollar 150 so a reduction of dollar
Thirty is there and you can further
proceed with uh maybe strike payment
method or Paypal payment method after
filling out the user details so this is
how
um this the payment process is so easy
and this coupon code is applicable till
fifth of the December so uh please like
if you are interested and you want to
Avail this opportunity and like uh so
please go and start enrolling yourself
now one more thing if
uh anyone who is like Landing up to this
particular Pace it's our landing page of
the program and uh we have also
Incorporated the payment link here on
the landing page also so if anyone is
interested in any of the uh tenure they
can simply click on the tenure and again
type just the coupon code that is take
20 and proceed with the
payment option and discount code and you
can simply write here
take 20
apply
I guess there is yeah discount code
apply see the total has now been changed
that is dollar 120. so this is how you
can uh proceed with the payment check
out throughout both of the pages that is
program page as well as the landing page
and
um
so this was all about the resources the
registration and the scholarship part if
anyone is having any query they can ping
me directly on my email address that is
marketing at the rate omics logic thank
you so shigori has already shared the
details so it's marketing omicslogic.com
even the official number that is plus
919876-134120 it's active on WhatsApp
also so we can directly get in touch and
we can uh have a telephony conversation
if you feel so that you have some
queries and you want to get it resolved
so this was all about the registration
part and the payment process and the
scholarship so if anyone is having any
kind of query related related to
registration please feel free to Ping in
the chat box and I'll be there to answer
your queries thank you
over to you srikauri
all right uh so I guess the participants
have no further queries and we are good
to end today's meeting and if the
participants are having any um other
queries uh you can uh feel free to reach
out to the contact details that I've
shared in the chat
uh and there's one query any further
discounts for uh lmic
[Music]
uh so it's low income country if I'm not
wrong uh so uh
we can definitely like we have a
scholarship form
for uh like if you you further want more
uh scholarship so you can mail us at a
marketing either at omixlogic.com and
then we can provide you with the
scholarship form and then we can further
discuss it with the internal team and
get back to you so uh definitely we can
help you out with a more scholarship or
discounts
and then we have another query how long
the session will be for courses is it
daily basis
um so uh no it's not daily based uh we
have set particular dates when the
session would be conducted and like the
sessions the program is hybrid some of
these sessions would be live and some of
the sessions would be asynchronous
depending upon if the Hands-On like if
we are doing Hands-On and it's the
Practical apart is more so the sessions
would be live obviously and when if
something conceptual leads to be get
covered we can uh have like we can maybe
send you asynchronously and you can go
through and then maybe when we conduct
the live q a sessions or through online
mental support you can get your queries
clarified
all right uh so I guess that's all the
queries and along the way if you're
having any queries please feel feel free
to reach out and with that I hope you
were able to learn something new today
from today's webinar and I look forward
to seeing you all for the uh art program
as well and with that thank you everyone
for joining today's webinar and have a
great day
thank you everyone